Obama starts by sitting down with
General Petraeus and the other military
commanders and hearing from them
directly not from the press not from the
admission ministration from but from the
people on the ground and also the Iraqis
he's got to sit down and hear from
Maliki and other leaders in Iraq what
would make the most sense he has said he
wants to withdraw absolutely but he
wants to withdraw responsibly his line
was we have to be as careful you know
getting out as we were careless getting
in so I don't think he can say anything
until he's actually had those
conversations and figured out how both
to withdraw but withdraw in a way that
maximizes the stability of the country
and that ensures we're not going to
leave and have absolute chaos follow or
worse a worse regional conflagration the
other thing he's got to do is make the
tour of the region talk to the Saudis
talk to the Turks talk to the Jordanians
to the people in the Gulf states but
actually also talk to the EU and I think
as far as Pakistan and India and talk
about how we stabilize the entire region
so everyone has a stake in making sure
that Iraq doesn't fall apart as we
withdraw but everyone also has a stake
in ensuring that there is a some
prospect of greater economic development
and political development for the whole
region
you